这条视频会很长,但是很实用
有如果你现在在处在生活的评讯线,或者是处在
或者是学了很的东西,但是用不出来
生活很密码,这条视频可能会对你会用
我们打操吧,然后天夜晚了,天夜黑了,想干哪儿就说哪儿
这是我发现我们很多老会计呀,不是不学习
也不是不努力
但是学了东西以后的话,不知道怎么用
就甚至第一步该怎么做
都不知道
我今天要和大家分享的东西可能会有为我们
以往的长时或者认知
那就对了
如果你以往的人是对的,你动力应该有你想的
你许如果没有,那你就应该听一些不压的声音
我们很多人
很大的问题就是从小接受的教育,不停地学习,不停地学习,不停地学习
其实这个不一定是对的
在我们社群里还分享过这么一件事,就很多人
他上二人上二人,你上三年,上三年,上四年
五年,你也就说,上三年,上一回,应该有好工作了,结果发现
等出来以后发现能工作的闷人
就从来没有想过我学这个东西到底是用在什么地方的
就我们很凭凭的原因是什么
从来没有研究过怎么赚钱
怎么能够学义是用
对吧 你的父母没有办法告诉你
老师学校又不交
社会上的话呢
老板应该也不会高级
让你自由不学习
于真正是出带一个很明白的状态
没有人跟你讲
然后
我而且看神奇的事实有时候
我跟你分享一些怎么状态方法
居然还会能说
那些教你专家人都是想赚你钱
我觉得是医存之事
我出门
买个包子
买包子的人想象中
想象中的钱
我出门买个什么东西
买个颜料那个颜料的人想象中的想象中的钱
只要是多想赚你钱没问题
只要证了这个钱
这个价值是合适的
是合理的能给你提供价值
那这么想有怎么样呢
所以你要学的是分辨
什么样的消费是
是合理的
我先指出大家第一个问题
不要一直学一直学一直学
你不是有盘
就你应该花更多神奇思考一个问题
我把我的时间用来学什么指学
真正有用的指示
而不是让你把它造的指示
然后
学一条
可能花一周一个月甚至半年的时间
把一个真正有用的指示学出来
那本种出来
有的时候就一个很简单的
那怕你已经觉得我早就动了指示
你要早动的话你早就有东西了
你早就有你想要有东西了
对我没有说你不懂
真正有的指示把它用出来
那这个指示就是你在了
那我今天和大家分享一个真正有的指示
可能你听过
但是还是一句话
看法你到了有没有东西
没东西对不起
你不知道
我翻完副会面说
如果我想赚钱会做两年生
第一我会去购建别人需要的产品
第二我会去学习赢笑
不要跟我说你知道
对吧
首先我们说购建别人需要的东西
只要别人需要
你能给别人听过价值
别人就会给你收益
那什么样的需求
是一定是刚虚呢
对
有了意思
比如说建肥
比如说拍这段视频
比如说赚钱
所以如果你的产品真的能把
给别人想费
你真的能辩卖
你就能赚钱
对吧
你真的能学交会别人怎么去做短视频
你就能赚钱
你真的能交别人
帮我被人赚到钱
你就能赚到钱
那很能说
这不是骗怎么注意
你过的思绿出来了
记住了
只要你能够帮助别人赚到钱
你就可以赚钱
很能够廢话
对吧
我自己都赚不到钱
我还交别人赚钱
不是骗子吗
好 现在让我来告诉你
你可以会赚钱
我再重复一遍
那你为什么不会呢
因为你从来没有研究过
你从来没有学习过
你等得不用高分
啊
其实有很多人会告诉你
在这么赚钱等
大家如果读过官员求的话
就是巴菲特
写巴菲特以为说
巴菲特的话
那在很小的时候
读过以为说
叫一千种
赚一千块钱的方法
巴菲特就是从那本书里起门了
然后通过那本书起门了以后
他知道怎么赚钱了
所以
这本书虽然很久很久很久很久
等书
但是你现在仍然可以拿来看
看一看哪些东西
当时的书是什么样子的
现在可不可以拿来用
一千种一千块钱的方法
你不用一上来就中一百万
你也不需要一上来中十万
特别一万
你可以先中
先从一千块钱开始
然后是一万
对吧
那么一千种的话
你可以去尝试
对吧
去找那种
没什么成本的
或者成本很低的
然后去尝试
你可以先先中吧
对吧
那
从了书里子来还有很多书
比如说什么
什么百万中外
对吧
一百万钱的起动
就在一百米级的起动
就这些书都可以
你都可以尝试
还那个乱眼
如果尝门比较低
然后没需要什么尝门的吧
你就去尝试
大不了就失败嘛
再是下一个
然后我给你个手建议
就是每次尝试
都不可以把它进入下来
发不到广数
每次尝试
你怎么做呢
成功来着失败了
失败的原因是吗
把它放在广数
这样的话
你可以获得用户
就获得去关注
你要知道
很多人都想干这个事
他们不敢干
他们还怕失败
他们想有个人
实现成功有高速的
那你就去干净的事情吧
一千种
你总能找到那么一块
或两块
可能是欧黑的吧
但这个时候其实你已经有用户了
这样的话
你已经转到钱了
拿牌赚一千块钱做事先
然后开始赚一样钱
对吧
然后你把这个方法
分享给别人
我就是怎么做的
就去尝试
对不对
所以这样的话
你就给别人一块
需要的产品
你自己也不能够钱了
而且同时把这个东西
也卖这个
你不要着急反馍
你自己去思考
你去思考
是不是怎么回事
是不是这么个道理
为什么很远不做呢
太难了
他老娘等别人去
去试完了以后告诉我
要了的话
你就特别害怕试办
也不然就等靠邀
习惯了思维完一圈打不开
对吧
但是你去做的也是这种机会
搬来我说了
就是我们从小的时候
有点多所
但是你听不懂
我不想想那个人的
我们从小的时候父母叫不了我们
学校不叫我们社会
不叫我们
对吧
所以我们不会不会学
不会赚钱
好教续是
几乎所有人都一样
但是你可以卖出这一步
好吧
让我们回顾刚才的句话
如果我想赚钱
那么我会做两顶设
这一件事的话
就够建访别人需要的产品
第二块的话
想办法把东西卖出去
然后
再往上的一句话
同样花那么多时间
学习学习学习学习
你不是纠盘
不是你气很多
这是就可以得分的
你要做的事
花认真花时间
经历认透一个真正有用的道理
把它用出来
你的人生
就改变了
比如
杀一个导人